that ending I know throw magical magical
and I remember shooting it and being
like man this feel is really right I
think it's like ultimately you're so
torn also you're so fulfilled when you
watch it you're like oh good news right
what it then floating up into the sky
what does that signify to you I mean
it's kind of like when when you're in
love right and if you're truly in love I
think the world kind of just falls away
and it's just you and that person and I
think that that's what we were trying to
do and ultimately you we didn't even
want people to necessarily notice it
just like was a feeling of us bringing
up instead of theirs oh they're on a
crane going up and I think we've I think
hopefully refold it up will be one
outfit I didn't even notice it then I
went back and I watch I was like that's
how I felt but then they're actually
loading yes I will say I was a little
bit bummed for mr. John Ambrose McLaren
who is you where you were like a team
I remember you're into it yes you're
right do you think that there should
have been more of a conversation or is
that the way to kind of end that
relationship think that their
relationship like they're so in tune
with each other just as friends right
and I think that what we try to do cuz
we shot that scene many times with a lot
of dialogue and then no dialogue and it
ended up being like the no dialogue and
it was just like they're so connected
and they knew that it was the right
decision without really saying anything
right so he cut all the dialogue out and
it I think turned out like sometimes you
don't have to say anything you just know
you know do you think there's room for
him in the third movie I think there's
always room for Jordan Fisher um but
yeah I mean I think so I think so how do
you think people are gonna feel about
the break-up in this movie I think I
think they're gonna feel way more I
think a lot of people are going in like
Peter Kaminsky fans and I think the
movie really honestly sways that so I
think people are gonna feel confused
like I felt confused everyday driving
home from work I was like what Scott
what what is she going through what's
happening I'm conflicted as well so I
hope I hope that they feel confused that
I'm like I did my job right
you did such a good job on this by the
way seriously how do you hope that that
ending sets up like what are they what
kind of trials and tribulations do they
go in into furs for the third one yeah I
mean I think she just really starts to
make decisions for herself that might be
unpopular but I think at the end of the
day as a young woman like you have to
protect your own heart and make the
decisions I feel truly right for you
regardless of the other people that
surround you and I think at the end of
the day Lara Jean loves love and she
loves the guys but at the end today I
know that she's good on her own as well
so we'll see but it's very satisfying
like yeah girl get your life the third
book right we see them in college yeah
so is that gonna follow suit with a
third movie there's a lot like a lot of
the third movie is based off around
college yeah talking to the writer miss
Jenny yes and I said what do you want to
see really in this third movie and she
had talked about how we're gonna see
real-life issues come into play when it
comes to Lara Jean and Peter's
relationship do you agree with that or
how do you how do you feel I first sure
agree with that I think we tackle like
the third movie is definitely the most
mature movie out of it all and we tackle
a lot of like first like questions and
first you know actions and stuff so it's
definitely we tackle more like real real
life because there's really no
distractions it's just him and I and
figure it out yeah you did say going
into this movie the scene that you
wanted to be in the second movie was the
snow scene with Jordan is that what
scene from the third book do you want to
see make the cut in the third movie girl
I mean we spent a lot of time in Korea
shooting so I think if that shows
because we're there for so long I hope
that they just show a lot of Korea and
also be like I want to celebrate the
culture so I think it's really important
that we keep as much of Korea in the
movie as possible
that's a good answer I'm so excited for
that too and before I let you go
Valentine's Day plans yes I mean listen
I'm hoping obviously asleep because I'm
tired but I hope it's just dinner and
stay inside and a dinner and a movie and
sleeping I seen this movie yet parts of
it parts of it hard for him to watch no
because he's so supportive of it and
ultimately he just wants the best for me
so I think that he's really excited and
but he'll be like he'll be like oh so
it's me and your two other boyfriends
again you know it's so odds of them
gonna say do you think that he's gonna
be team Peter or our team John yeah
[Music]